Altyazı M.K.
Arkadaşlar.
M.K.
Altyazı M.K.
Evet, bir yazı girin, yazı arkadaşlar girilmiş, başka bir şey var, I will stream, tamam.
String'i tutuyor, ben şöyle de girişi yapayım, scene, getline, string başlık dosyası da ayrı edilmemiş, bazen böyle takılıyor, evet.
Yerde bir tuhaplık var, neyse oraya geleceğim, soru şu, yazı örneğin, girilen yazı, şimdilik şöyle alalım, scene, str, bir dakika tut scene, benim şey de sapıttı belki, arka plandaki interlisans, tamam şimdi oldu.
Bu yazıda karakterlerin şöyle olduğunu düşünelim, A, B, C, Y, E, D, R, E bir takım karakterler var.
Yazının içinde sadece unique olan karakterler kalacak, yani unique olmayanlar silinecek.
Örneğin, örneği basit bir string üstünde gösterelim.
A, B, C, D, E, F, A, B, 4, 5, 8, 7, 2, 3, 4, 5, D, G, S, W, T.
A, unique olmadığı için silindi, altta gösterelim, A silindi, B, unique olduğu için kaldı, C silindi, D, E, F, arkadaşlar, D, E, F, D unique değil, E, F.
Ve unique olanlar silindi, dört silinecek.
Ama bu sıra korunacak.
Anlaşıldı değil mi?
Eğer zaten soru sadece unique olanlar kalsın olsaydı, soruyu çok basit bir şekilde arkadaşlar, algoritm, parçalık dosyasını include ederdim.
Ve, stringi önce sort ederdim.
Stood sort, str begin, str end.
Ve, sort ettiğim stringi, unique hale getirirdim.
Onun içinde unique algoritması var, hatırlayın.
Unique, str begin, str end, logic end döndürüyordu.
Ve, str'nin range arrays fonksiyonunu çağırırım.
Stringin de bir konteyner olduğunu unutmayın.
str'nin end'i, hatırladınız değil mi?
Arrays remove gidiyor mu?
Ve şimdi,
see out,
str,
ve bu fonksiyon çağrılarından sonra,
Arkadaşlar, tekrar yazdırıyorum.
Unique olanlar kaldı.
Onun dışındakiler simdi ama sıra bozuldu.
Bir yazı girin.
Elektrik birden kessince benim ide ayarlarım da gitti.
Evet, bir yazı girin.
Mesela,
bugün elektrik kesildiği için,
iki ayrı kayıt yapıldı.
Yapılıyor.
Arkadaşlar,
arkadaşlar, evet.
Yazdırdığım kısım,
şurada iki kere yazdırmışım.
Evet, arkadaşlar,
str begin,
str end,
str'yi yazdırdım.
Ama tabii boşluk karakterleri girdiğim için separatör oldu.
Boşluk karakterlerini girmeyeceğim.
O yüzden get life oksiyonunu çağırmıştım.
Bugün kursu,
iki ayrı ders,
boşluk yok,
olarak yaptık.
Evet, bakın.
Mesela şu karakterler yün itmiş.
Ama şimdi soru,
sırasıyla karakterleri korumak.
Yani örneğin şöyle olsaydı,
a, b, c, d, b, c, f, y,
a, b, c,
arkadaşlar, d,
d kaldı,
b,
unique olmadığı için gitti.
Evet.
c,
unique olmadığı için gitti.
Size de mi sordular bir arkadaşım?
diyor ki,
ben de bunu tam anlattığının sıraya ihtiyacım oldu diyor.
Güzel.
Arkadaşlar, şimdi,
bu tür soruların en kolay çözümü şu.
String'i dolaşacaksınız.
String'te tabii ki bir set kullanacaksınız.
Bu unorder set olabilir, set olabilir.
Soruyu tam şimdi sormamın nedeni,
kullanacağımız set, bit set de olabilir.
Son derece basit.
İlk defa karakter karşımıza çıktığında,
onu silmeyeceğiz.
Ama onu sete koyacağız.
Arkadaşlar,
karakterlerin her birini dolaştığımızda da,
set de var mı?
Ona bakacağız.
Set de varsa,
o zaman,
o zaman demek ki,
ikinci kez ya da eninci kez çıkmış,
sileceğiz.
Set de yoksa,
silmeyeceğiz.
Ama onu da sete insert edeceğiz.
Deniz anladınız mı?
Çözümü anladınız mı?
Bu herhangi bir konteyner için geçerli.
Yani soru şöyle de sorulabilirdi.
Aslında string ile kafanız biraz daha karışmasın diye,
vektör versiyonunu soralım.
Bakın,
vektörün,
int açılımı,
ivek,
yüz tane ve olsun,
generate,
ivek begin,
ivek end,
arkadaşlar,
tırt tane ve olsun,
ivek begin,
ivek end,
by rent,
0,
99,
evet,
c print,
ivek,
Evet, bakın.
Yalnız bunu C++'la kodlarken,
çok dikkatli olmanız gerekiyor.
Geçen,
iterator invalidation'dan bahsetmiştik.
Orada anlattıklarımı,
kesinlikle uygulamanız gerekiyor.
Ama şimdi soruyu biraz daha ilginç kılan.
Normalde burada set kullanacağım ya,
set yerine bit set kullanabilir miyim?
Arkadaşlar,
cevap tabii ki bit set de kullanabilirim.
Bit set'in zaten kullanım amaçlarından biri bu.
Özellikle,
burada da değerlerin 0,
99 aralığında olduğunu söyledim.
O zaman,
onları tutması için,
bit set partik dosyasını dahil edelim.
Bit set'in,
Arkadaşlar,
yüz açılımı türünden,
pz.
Şimdi bütün bitler 0.
Vektörü dolaşıyorum.
Bu arada şuraya kadar,
bir derleyip çalıştıralım.
Evet,
bakın şimdi,
vektörü dolaşıyorum.
auto iter eşittir,
ibek'in begin'i,
while iter eşit olmadığı sürece,
ibek'in end'i,
if,
bs,
test ya da köşeli parantez,
yıldız iter,
eğer bu arkadaşlar,
true ise,
demek ki sette var.
Sette olduğuna göre,
tekrar etmiş demektir.
Bu durumda,
sileceğim.
Ama silme için hatırlayın,
ibek'in,
e-reizini çağırıyorum,
iteratör konumunu veriyorum,
iter,
fakat geri dönüş değerini,
yine iteratörde sakladım.
Bu durumda,
er-reiz fonksiyonu,
silinen öğeden,
sonraki öğeyi,
öğeye iteratör oldu.
Bu durumda iteratörü arttırmıyorum.
Zaten bir sonraki öğeyi gösteriyor.
Takip edebiliyor muyuz?
Else,
bit sette yok.
O zaman,
bs,
iter,
eşittir,
true,
yıldız iter,
ve
artı artı iter.
Koda bakın bir daha,
Deniz sizin yazdığınız kodda,
böyle miydi?
Ha burada normal set,
unorder set vs.
kullanabilirim.
Ama bu tür sorular için,
en pratiği bit set.
Çünkü bellekte artışık olarak tutuluyor arkadaşlar.
Bit set işlemlerle çok hızlı bir şekilde erişiyorsunuz.
Zaten değer sayısı da belli olduğuna göre,
böyle yazabilirim.
Ama yine de bir hata görüyorsanız,
hatayı söyleyin.
Bir daha bakalım.
iter,
ibekinendine eşit olmadığı sürece,
bit set'in,
yıldız iter,
indisti elemanının,
true olup olmadığına baktım.
True ise,
iter konumundaki nesneyi,
eres fonksiyonuyla sildim.
Ve iter'e yeni değer olarak,
iterator invalidation'dan kaçınmak için,
eresin geri dönüş değerini atadım.
Eres zaten,
silinen öğeden,
sonraki öğenin konumunu döndürüyor.
Eğer bit set'te yoksa,
arkadaşlar,
bit set'in,
o indisti elemanını,
true yaptım.
Ve iteratörü arttırdım.
Bu tür sorularda,
aklınıza bit set de gelsin.
Yani,
burada,
look up table olarak,
normal set kullanmak,
arkada ikili arama adı olduğu için,
maliyeti daha fazla yükseltecekti.
almışım.
Almışım.
Evet maalesef tekrar elektrik kesildi.
Şu anda herkes duyuyor mu?
Bugün talihsiz bir gün.
En son nereyi duyduğunuz bilmiyorum.
Kayıtta bu sefer umarım problem olmaz.
Arkadaşlar sorunun çözümünü bitirdik.
Oraya kadar takip edebildiniz mi?
Şimdi aralığı biraz daraltalım.
Unicomya sayısı biraz daha artsın.
Evet görüyorsunuz.
Mesela Bitset'in kullanımına arkadaşlar güzel bir örnek.
Bu arada bakın şuraya kadar geldi.
0, 45, 48, 13, 39, 38.
Şurada ilk tekrar eden sayı 3'ü atladı.
41, 41'i atladı.
33 arkadaşlar.
41'i yazdı.
İkinci 41'i atladı.
33'ü atladı.
Ve ondan sonra 4.
Öyle gidiyor 33 varmış gerçekten.
Sorunun çözümünü anlamayan var mı?
String'i ele alırken char'ları integral promotion ile int'e çevirip mi yapmalıyız?
Aslında soru da string olmasında alian hiçbir ilave faktörü yok.
String de bir container.
Dolayısıyla String'de de tutulan öğeler zaten tar.
O zaman da string de şöyle olacaktı.
O kısmını göstereyim.
String.
Str.
Bir şekilde string'in doğduğunu düşünün.
Buradaki bit set, bit set'in aslıyla 128 tane karakter olduğu için 128 açılımı olacaktı.
İvek, Str'nin begin'i olacaktı arkadaşlar.
İter, Str'nin end'i olmadığı sürece vs, yıldız iter.
Ha, burada zaten char integral promotion ile int'e yükseltilecek.
Ama açık şekilde yükseltseniz de herhangi bir problem yok.
Anladınız değil mi?
String'in de yine aynı şekilde arkadaşlar rs fonksiyonu var.
Str'nin rs'de.
İşte bu kadar.
Anlaşıldı mı?
Evet.
Peki şimdi bit set'e devam edelim.
En son bit set operatörleri gördük.
Bit set veya bit set özel veya bit set sağa kaydırma, bit set sola kaydırma.
Orada not olarak şunu söyledik.
Bs bir bit set nesnesi ise burada bu bit set sağa kaydırma operatörü.
Yani böyle yazmakla bs'nin operatör left right shift fonksiyonunu çağır, ona 12 argüman olarak gönder, aynı.
Ama formatlı yazma işlemine gelince böyle yazarsak arkadaşlar bu durumda operatör öncelik yönü soldan sağa olduğu için önce bu işlem yapılacak ve ondan sonra 12 değeri yazılacak.
Ama biz bunu yazdırmak istiyorsak dedik, öncelik parantezi kullanmak zorundayız.
Şimdi bir de dönüşüm fonksiyonlarına bakalım.
Arkadaşlar bit set'ten ham sayıya ve string'e dönüşüm var.
Bu fonksiyonların ismi bit set'in üye fonksiyonu bunlar to string ve to ulong.
Ve to ulong.
Önce bunları bir görelim.
Bit set'in 32 açılımı arkadaşlar bs.
Arada bir takım işlemler yapılmış.
Bs'nin to ulong.
Ama buraya dikkat edin mesela benim derleyicimde long türü 4 byte, unsign long türü 8 byte.
Dolayısıyla büyük bir string olduğunda, örneğin şöyle.
Arkadaşlar bir set'in 32 açılımı olmasaydı, bir set'in 80 açılımı olsaydı sığmama durumu da olabilirdi.
İşte o zaman exception prove edecek yine.
Mesela bakın.
Hatta şimdiden exception prove edebilir diye.
Buradaki gönderilecek exception'in türü, yani unsign long'a dönüştürüyorsanız, unsign long sınırına sığmıyorsa,
overflow error.
Bu da runtime error'den kalıtım yoluyla elde edilmiş bir sınıf.
Yani böyle de yakalayabilirim.
Runtime error ile de yakalayabilirim.
Arkadaşlar, overflow error ile de yakalayabilirim.
std-exit başlık dosyasını da dahil edelim.
Over tool over error.
bs'nin
to
U-long fonksiyonu.
Geri dönüş değerini
unsign long tür'den bir değişkende sakladım.
Ve değeri yazdırdım.
Ciheart
Warriors.
abone ol
mam
Bakın overflow hatası oldu.
Azaltalım.
Şimdi 5 milyon 417 bin 554.
Sınıfın, buraya dikkat, arada sadece bir farkı var ama tamamen değişiyor.
Bakınız ilk haline geri döndüreyim.
To long yerine to long fonksiyonunu çağıralım.
Bu fonksiyonun geri dönüş değeri unsigned long long.
Dolayısıyla auto type bidakçımı kullandığım için var değişkeninin türü de unsigned long long.
Şimdi bakalım exception prove edecek mi?
Exception prove etmedi çünkü bir taşma olmadı.
Sınıfın string fonksiyonu arkadaşlar string'e dönüştürüyor.
Bu sefer count tersini yapalım.
Bit set 64
bs
to string
eğer hiç argüman geçmezseniz to string fonksiyonuna
to string fonksiyonu doğrudan 0 ve 1 karakterlerini kullanıyor.
Yani örneğin c alt
Gördünüz.
Ama
eğer bir karakter verirsem
0 yerine bunu kullan demek.
Bakın 0 yerine A koydu.
İkinci bir argüman verirsem
bir yerine de B koyacak.
Sting'e.
Evet.
Bunu istediğim gibi ayarlayabilirim.
Örneğin x ve y.
Takip edebildik mi?
Evet.
Arkadaşlar şimdi
şu structure binding hakkında biraz konuşalım.
Yine bugünkü dersi böyle bitireceğiz.
Biraz da yine algoritmalara bakacağız.
Algoritma derken bir tanesini atladık.
O arada konu başka bir yere gitti.
Binary search algoritması.
Binary search algoritması
yine sıralı bir vere yapısında
adı üstünde
binary search'ı uyguluyor.
Yalnız burada binary search
boolean değer döndürüyor.
Yani binary search'te
var mı yok mu
onu bulabilirsiniz.
Eğer aranmada
konum ihtiyacınız varsa
lower bound
upper bound
equal range
o fonksiyonlardan
birini çağırmanız
gerekecek.
Ben lower bound
upper bound'u
anlatmıştım ama
binary search'ı
sanki göstermedim
diye hatırlıyorum.
Arkadaşlar
vektörün
hemen basit bir
binary search kodu
oluşturalım.
Vektörün
int açılımı
ivec
random fill
artık random fill
de kullanmayalım.
Bari generate
fonksiyonunu öğrendik
onu tekrarında
yapmış oluruz.
Algoritm
generate
ibeg
plugin
end
kendi jeneratörümü
kullanayım.
Mesela standart
fonksiyonunu da
kullanabilirdim.
Hadi onu da bir
hatırlatalım.
Time başlık dosyasını
dahil ediyorum.
C time
csd
delik
tabi
bizim yerimizde
müthiş bir
random kütüphanesi
varken
C'deki
rant
fonksiyonunu
çağırmamız
çok akılcı
değil ama
yine de olsun.
Arkadaşlar
s rant
her defasında
ayrı bir sayı
zinciri
oluşsun diye
static cast
unsigned
time
null ptr
Şimdi jeneratörüme
lambda ifadesi
veriyorum.
Return
rant
efendim
mod
arkadaşlar
in
vektör
başlık
dosyası
noktalı
virgül
evet yazdıralım
jprint
ibek
ama
sort edecek mi?
Bakın
küçükten büyüğe
sort ediyorum
sort
ibek
begin
end
şimdi küçükten büyüğe
sıralı
utility
başlık
dosyası
int
valk
see out
aranan değer
see in
valk
if
binary search
ibek
begin
end
valk
true
döndürürse
see out
evet var
as
see out
hayır
yok
evet
aranan değer
örneğin
evet var
aranan değer
yok
ayır
ama konum
bulmak isteseydim
bu arada
tabi ki
prediket alan
bir overloadu var
ona da gösterelim
mesela
sortu şöyle
çalıştırsaydım
büyükten küçüğe
sıralama
burada da
binary search'e de
aynı
predicate'i
vermem
gerekiyordu
creator
tabi ki
burada
algoritmanın
karmaşıklığı
o
logen
evet
var
fakat
o konuma
erişmem
gerekiyorsa
o zaman
arkadaşlar
hadi onu da
yapalım
oto iter
eşittir
lower bound
creator'ı
sileyim
lower bound
evic begin
evic end
lower bound
onun insert edilebileceği
ilk konumu döndürüyordu
var
şöyle yazmalıyım
değil mi
if
iter
arkadaşlar
eşit değilse
evic end
ve
yıldız iter
eşit değilse
var
siyahut
bulundu
iter konumu
oyunun konumu
genel mantığı
anladınız
değil mi
şimdi
değerler şöyle ya
4 5 7
örneğin
7'yi
arasaydım
bana
lower bound
şu konumu
verecekti
end
konumu
olmayacak
ve bu konumda
köye
aradığım
değer olacak
neden böyle
diyorum
çünkü örneğin
arkadaşlar
8'i arasaydım
bana bu
konumu
verecekti
ama ben bu
konumda
köyenin
8 olmadığını
anladığımda
8'in
burada
olmadığını
anlayacağım
dolayısıyla
böyle bir
sorgulama
yapmanız
gerekir
binary search'ın
kendisi
sadece
var mı yok mu
anlamında
boolean değer
döndürüyor
bir grup
algoritma
daha var
onları da
bir göstermek
istiyorum
sonra konuyu
değiştireceğim
arkadaşlar
bakın
minimum
maximum
operations
daha önce
bir ikisine
bakmıştık
özellikle
göstermediğim
diğer fonksiyonlara
da
değineceğim
şimdi
önce
max
ile başlayalım
range
alan
bir fonksiyon
değil
range
alan fonksiyon
max
element
max fonksiyonunun
iki overload'u var
ya iki değerden
büyüğünü
bulacak
ya da
initializer liste alacak
algoritm
başlık dosyasında
örneğin
yalnız
max'a dikkat
max'ın
geri dönüş
değeri
referans
yani
örneğin
int x eşittir
y eşittir
max
x
y
şöyle yazarsanız
auto
int
ref
auto
int ref ne demek
auto ref
re
eşittir
max'ın
geri dönüş
değeri
referans
dolayısıyla
şu anda
re demek
y demek
ama tabi
referans
değişkende
tutmak zorunda
değilim
şöyle de
yazabilirim
ya da doğrudan
bir değişkende
saklamadan
c out
max
ya da belki
bir fonksiyona
göndereceğim
tabu fonksiyonların
hepsi
const
x
pr
eğer şöyle
yazsaydım
initializer list
mesela bakalım
p eşittir
m eşittir
int
y eşittir
bakın
en büyük değer
imiş
şunu
yapalım
max
gibi
benzer
şekilde
min
fonksiyon
da var
onu
örnekte
göstermeyim
max yerine
min koyun
işte
her iki
overloadu
da var
yine
max
elementi
ise
iteratör
parametreli
algoritma
iteratör
döndürüyor
yani örneğin
arkadaşlar
vektör
ya da
herhangi bir
konteyner
vektör
string
açılımı
svec
algoritmayı da
bunun üstünden
gösterelim
arkadaşlar
max
element
svec
begin
end
default
yine
l'si
kullanıyor
ama
kendi
karşılaştırma
kriterim
varsa
kendi
karşılaştırma
kriterimi
yine
max
elementin
3.
parametresine
binary
predikat olarak
geçebilirim
auto
iter
ya da
bir değişkende
tutmak
ona yarışmak
istemiyorsanız
sadece
değeriyle
ilgileniyorsanız
doğrudan
geri dönüş
değeri olan
iteratörü
bir referans
edebilirsiniz
zeliha
min
element
range'deki
en küçük
öğeyi
döndürüyor
hatta
bakın
daha
eğlenceli
hale
getirelim
vektörün
date
açılımı
d-back
date
başlık
postasını
dahil
edelim
d-back
date'in
randomı
max
element
d-back
begin
end
min
element
d-back
begin
end
date
sınıfı
küçüktür
operatörünü
overload
ettiği
için
bir problem
yok
en büyüğü
ağustos
imiş
en küçük
tarihte
Aralık
imiş
min
max
element
pair
döndürüyor
iteratör
pair'i
döndürüyor
yani her ikisini de
elde etmek
istiyorsam
o zaman
min
max
element
yine
d-back
begin
bu arada
vektör olması
şartlı
poverty
iteratör
kategorisinde
d-back
end
arkadaşlar
hatta burada
izleyin
ilginç bir şey
yapalım
date
sınıfının
bakalım
üye
fonksiyonlarına
date
my date
first string
implement edilmemiş
implement edilseydi
daha eğlenceli
olurdu
arkadaşlar
çünkü örneğin
stringin büyüklüğüne göre
yani tarihi yazıya dönüştürüp
o yazının büyüklüğüne göre
seçecektim
ama şimdi
l'si kullanalım
auto
birazdan
mercek altına
alacağımız range
bass for loop'u
kullanıyorum
auto
min
i min
iter min
iter
max
eşittir
şimdi artık
bu iteratör konumundaki
nesneleri
erişeyim
sea alt
yıldız
i min
new life
yıldız
emax
en küçük ve en büyük tarihi
yazdırdım
18 haziran
25 hekim
yine bu grupta
c++17 ile
eklene
clamp fonksiyonu var
elektronikçilerin
bildiği bir işlem
değil mi
clamp
clamp ne yapıyor
arkadaşlar
elinizde bir değer var
bir de bir
aralık var
örneğin
aralığımız
90 olsun
elimizde bir de
değer var
eğer değer bu aralıkta
kalıyorsa
değerin kendisini
döndürüyor
minden küçükse
mini döndürüyor
max'dan büyükse
max'ı döndürüyor
yani değeri
bu aralığa
hapsediyor
sokuyor
böylece
o aralık dışındaki
değerleri
normalize edip
minimum değeri
maksimum değeri
çekiyorsunuz
ama aralık içindeki
değerler
aynı şekilde
kalıyor
bakın çok basit
bir fonksiyon ama
bazı yerlerde
çok işe yarıyor
clamp
izleyin
şuradan bulalım
implementasyonunu
göstereceğim
yazmakla zaman
kaybetmeyelim
evet
arkadaşlar bakın şimdi
ne kadar güzel
implement etmiş
şimdi bu
cpp reference'daki
implementasyon
iki tane
overload'u var
bir tanesi
less'i kullanıyor
arkadaşlar
ama
diğerini
implement etmiş
default overload'da
diğerini çağırırken
less function'ını
argüman olarak göndermiş
less function object'ini
dolayısıyla
ikinciye bakmamız
gerekiyor
şimdi
ikincinin
implementasyonu
bu
onu da koyalım
zaten
ne dediğimi
şimdi daha iyi anlayacaksınız
bakın şimdi
v
v value
low
birinci parametre
value
ikinci parametre
low
aralığın düşük değeri
üçüncü parametre
aralığın
yüksek değeri
şimdi
comp yerine
less'in olduğunu
düşünün
value
low'dan
küçükse
ifadenin
değeri
low
fernler
operatörün
herkes tarafından
bilinini
varsayıyorum
aksi halde
high value'dan
küçükse
arkadaşlar
o zaman
high
aksi halde
value'nun
kendisi
hemen
clamp için bir örnek
kod yazalım
iostream
bir vektör
oluşturalım
vektör
int
ivrek
yüz
0.99
değerleri
vereceğim
generate
algoritması
ile
generate
ivrek
begin
end
iron
0.99
şimdi buradaki
öğeleri
yazdırıyorum
kırk tane olsun
şeye print
ivrek
şimdi
dikkat
int
low
high
aralık
değerlerini
girin
tamam
arkadaşlar
şimdi
clamp
fonksiyonunun
geri dönüş
değerini
ne yapacağım
tekrar
vektöre
yazacağım
bunun için
transform
algoritmasını
kullanalım
transform
ivrek
begin
end
arkadaşlar
low
high
değerlerini
capture
ediyorum
int
x
return
st
clank
önce
değer
yani
x
sonra
low
high
planda
ifadesi
tekrar
üçüncü
parametreyi
almamışım
ivrek
begin
çok şık
bir kod
oldu
transfer
herkes
hatırlıyor
değil mi
böyle durumlarda
ben ham döngü
deyimi
kesinlikle
kullanmıyorum
isimlendirilmiş
fonksiyon her zaman
daha iyi
ivrek
bag'in
bu range
teki
öeleri
şu operasyondan
geçir
tekrar
aynı
range
yaz
az önce
jprint
yazdırmıştık
şimdi jprint
tekrar
yazdıralım
clamp'in
ne yaptığını
daha iyi
görmüş
oluruz
aralık değerlerine
girin
mesela
arkadaşlar
76'yı
70'e
çekecek
79'u
70'e
çekecek
32'yi
40'a
çekecek
6'yı
40'a
çekecek
ama
49 olduğu
gibi
kalacak
görüyorsunuz
değil mi
aralığı
biraz
değiştirelim
evet
10 için
10'u
20 yaptı
bulalım
86'yı
80 yaptı
clamp
sinyal
işleme
vesaire
tarafında da
çok sık
kullanılıyor
değil mi
evet
bu gruba
geri dönelim
şimdi
değinmediğimiz
algoritma
bu grupta
kalmadı
min
max'ı
gördük
arkadaşlar
clamp'i
gördük
min
element
max
min
element
fonksiyonlarını
gördük
şimdi
gelelim
structure
binding'e
arkadaşlar
C++
standardıyla
direklendiğini
defalarca
söyledik
structure
binding
birleşik
bir türün
öğelerine
ayrıştırılması
için
arkadaşlar
dilin
sentaksına
eklenen
bir araç
ama
aslında
arka planda
ne oluyor
buna zaman
ayırmamın
en önemli
nedeni
programcıların
profesyonel
tarafta da
structure
binding'i
tipik olarak
yanlış
anlamaları
arkadaşlar
diyelim ki
şöyle bir
yapı
nesnesi
var
C++
sınıf
structure
data
struct data
döndüren
data döndüren
bu fonksiyonu var
hatta kodu da yazalım
return
şimdi bu fonksiyonu çağıralım
ve önce bir sentaksımızı gösterelim
auto
x
y
z
eşittir
u
burada eşittir
kullanmanız
çoğunlukla tercih ediyoruz ama
aslında mecburi değil
ilk değer vermede
yine
direct
initialization
arkadaşlar
direct list
initialization
da
yazabilirim
yani bunlar arasında
anlamsal
açıdan
bir fark yok
burada önemli olan
şunu anlamanız
burada oluşturulan
değişkenler
int türden
değişkenler değil
yani sanki
koda bakan
herkesin
ilk aklına gelen
şu oluyor
herhalde diyor
ben şöyle bir
değişken
tanımlıyorum
int
x diye bir
değişken
tanımladım
fun'un geri döndürdüğü
yapı nesnesinin
elemanından
değerini aldı
hayır öyle değil
bakın
derleyicinin
ürettiği kod
şöyle
aslında
auto
şöyle deyin
compiler
generated
object
eşittir
foo
yani
derleyicinin
ürettiği kodla
oluşturulan
nesne
bu
structured
binding
sentaksında
virgüllerle
ayrılan
değişkenler
türünden
değil
doğrudan
eşittirin
sağ tarafındaki
ifadenin
türünden
yani
derleyici
böyle bir
kod için
hangi türden
değişken
oluşturuyor
söyleyin
arkadaşlar
cevap
data
türünden
bu ifadenin
türü
data
değil mi
evet
şimdi
buradaki
benim
cgo
ismini
verdiğim
değişken
data
türünden
bir
değişken
değil mi
dolayısıyla
eğer
gerçekten
böyle bir
kod
yazsaydım
geri dönüş
değeri olan
data
nesnesinin
bir
ası
v'si
bir de
c'si
olacaktı
değil mi
işte
buradaki
isimler
fonksiyonun
geri dönüş
değeri olan
data
nesnesinin
arkadaşlar
elemanlarına
eş
isimler
yani
x'in
kendisi
bir
değişken
değil
aslında
x
bu
fonksiyonun
geri dönüş
değerini
tutan
değişkenin
a
elemanına
verilen
bir
eş
isim
orasını
derleyici
hallediyor
burayı
anladık mı
dolayısıyla
siz böyle
bir
kod
yazsanız da
soru
data
sınıfının
copy
konstruktörü
ve
move
konstruktörü
olsaydı
data
sınıfının
move
konstruktörü
çağrılacak
mıydı
arkadaşlar
cevap
evet
eğer başka
daha uygun bir fonksiyon
yoksa
çağrılacaktı
yine aynı şekilde
bakın ben
bu fonksiyonun
geri dönüş
değeri
referans
olsaydı
mesela
data
x
ref
ve
x'i
referans
semantiliyle
döndürseydim
yerel
nesneye
referans
döndüremem
biliyorsunuz
fonksiyonu
şöyle
çağırsaydım
soru
bu durumda
x
y
ve z
x'in
y'nin
z'nin
türü
referans
mı
değil mi
soruyu
anlamaya
ve cevap
vermeye
çalışalım
cevap
referans
değil
bakın burası
çok önemli
en çok yanlış
anlaşılan yer
isterseniz
bir test edelim
necati nasıl
test edeceğiz
ya son derece
basit
eğer
x
intref
olarak
deklare
edilmiş
olsaydı
o zaman
is
same
using
bildirimde yapalım
ya da
is
bakın
reference
underscore
v'nin
decotype
x
açılımı
see out
gördünüz mü
yanlış
referans
olsaydı
doğru olacaktı
değerleyici peki
nasıl bir kod
üretti
yine aynı
şekilde
bakınız
aslında
referans
yapı nesnesinin
elemanlarına
değil
yapı nesnesinin
kendisine
yani
derleyicinin
ürettiği
kod
yine şöyle
auto
ref
data
eşittir
arkadaşlar
bu
bu durumda
derleyicinin
oluşturduğu
nesne
arkadaşlar
bir referans
şimdi takip
edebiliyor musunuz
benim
x'im
y
x y
ve z
değişkenim
bu referansın
elemanlarına
yani referansın
bağlandığı
nesnenin
elemanlarına
eşitsin
ama
x'in y'nin
z'nin
kendisi
ne
değil
referans
şimdi
structure
bindingden
faydalanabilmemiz
için
bu arada
dilin
standartları
burada
bazı kuralları
değiştirdi
c++
ile
ama
ben önce
değişmeyen
kuralları
söyleyeyim
arkadaşlar
bazı türler
doğrudan
core
syntax
olarak
standardın
kullandığı
terim
core
syntax
doğrudan
structured
binding'e
destek veriyor
bunlar
olsa nesin
hayır
o şekilde
bir
syntax yok
yani
köşeli
parantezinin
içine
referans
deklaratörü
pointer
vesaire
yazamazsınız
köşeli
parantezinin
içine
sadece
ve sadece
isimleri
yazabilirsiniz
tamam da
oraya geleceğim
ama
şöyle
olabilir
auto
şöyle
olabilir
const
auto
tabii
structure
binding
bir ihtiyaç
üzerine mi
çıktı
tabii
kesinlikle
zaten
c++
dışında
onlarca
dilde
benzer
syntax
vardı
bileşik bir
türü
elemanları
ayrıştırmak
için
oraya
geleceğim
zaten
birazdan
vakit
yeterse
const
niteleyicisini
kullanabilirsiniz
referans
deklaratörünü
ve yine
universal
referans
deklaratörünü
kullanabilirsiniz
evet
şimdi
pod dediğimiz
yapı türleri
için
doğrudan
dil tarafından
destek var
yani örneğin
data türünden
mini esne oluşturayım
data
my data
eşittir
bu
doğrudan
basit bir
structure olduğu için
structure
binding'e
doğrudan
izin veriyor
yani şunu
yazabilirim
auto
x
y
z
eşittir
my data
yani eşittir'in
sağ tarafındaki
ifade
ya da
küme parantezi
içindeki
ifade
ne olmak
zorunda
arkadaşlar
data
türünden
olmak
zorunda
bu da
data'nın
elemanları
sayıda
uyuşmazlık
olursa
syntax
hatası
mesela
burada
data'nın
3 tane
elemanı
var ama
2 tane
isim
kullandım
dolayısıyla
syntax
aykırı
arkadaşlar
eğer
gerçekten
kullanmayacağınız
değişken
varsa
yani bu
ayrıştırma
sonucunda
o zaman
onu
kullanmayacağınızı
göstermek için
underscore
kullanıyorsunuz
tabi buradaki
underscore
mecburi değil
yani ben buraya
necati yazsaydım da
bir syntax
hatası
olmayacaktı
ama underscore
kullanmak
bir
konvensiyon
olmuş durumda
ama
burada da
dikkat edin
c++23'de
bir değişiklik
yapıldı
ona değinmeyeceğim
buradaki
ismin
skopu
sanki
değişkeni
böyle
bildirmişim
gibi
arkadaşlar
bu
structured
bindingin
kullanıldığı
skop
bu neden
önemli
örneğin
şöyle bir
kod yazsam
auto
ab
underscore
my data
şimdi
syntax
hatası
olacak
ama
tabi
ben de
onu söyleyecektim
bakın burada
syntax hatasının
olmasının
nedeni
aynı ismi
birden fazla
varlığa
vermemiz
ama
burada
diyelim ki
iki
underscore
kullanabilirim
ama değişken
sayısı
uymak
zorunda
arkadaşlar
izleyin
eğer
sınıfın
private
veri elemanı
olsaydı
doğrudan
kullanamazdım
onları
structured
bindingde
ama
burada da
c++20 ile
bir değişiklik
yapıldı
sınıfın
kendi
üye
fonksiyonları
ve sınıfa
friend
fonksiyonlar
structured
bindingde
bunları
kullanabiliyorlar
yani şöyle bir
sınıf olsaydı
bu ilginç
c++20 ile
geldi bu
değişiklik
bakın
class
my class
bunlar sınıfın
private
veri elemanı
ben hep
örneklerde
int türünü
kullanıyorum
ama tabi
herhangi bir
tür olabilir
int
x
bu sefer
değiştirelim
int
x
kod yazmakta
uğraşmamak için
default
member
initializer
kullanıyorum
std
string
efendim
s
alian
double
deval
13.35
bakın
şöyle
diyebilir miyim
auto
arkadaşlar
işte
i
std
ve
eval
buna da
diyelim
arkadaşlar
av
belki bir
ortalama
diyelim
eşittir
burada da bir
my class
nesnesi olsun
m
eşittir
bunu yapabilmeniz
için elemanların
public olması
gerekiyor
yani
erişime açık
olması gerekiyor
ama şimdi bakın
buraya bir
üye fonksiyon
yazayım
void
u
public
view fonksiyonun
içinde az önceki
kodu
kullanayım
arkadaşlar
şu
küme
parantezi
fazla
değil mi
bakın konunun
legal olduğunu
görüyorsunuz
alian
bosker
diyor ki
underspor'ı
istediğimiz yere
koyabilir miyiz
tabii ki
sonuçta o bir
identif
hayır
yani
benim verdiğim
örnek
basit olsun
diye son
öğe'ye
kullanmayacağım
dedim
hangi öğe
öğe'ye
ya da öğeleri
kullanmayacağınız
sizi ilgilendirir
burayı anladık
değil mi
bu eklenti
C++20
standardıyla
geldi
yani
C++20'den
önce
bu yoktu
benzer şekilde
bakınız
bu kez
foo'yu
bir
pre-punction
yaptım
tabii
sentaks
hatası
ama
foo'ya
friend
bildirimiyle
erişim hakkı
verdim
friend
void
bu
bu da
friend olan
fonksiyonun
tanımı
yine
C++17'den
önce
bu sentaks
hatasıydı
C++20 ile
legal hale
geldi
yani artık
public olma
zorunluluğu
sadece
sınıfın
dışındaki
kodlar için
sınıfın
kendi fonksiyonları
ve sınıfa
friend fonksiyonlar
private
öğeleri de
structure
bindingde
kullanabiliyorlar
yine
C++20
standartından
önce
çok tuhaf
biraz da
anlamsız
bir sıkıntı
vardı
onu da bir
göstermek
istiyorum
izleyin
daha önceki
örneklerden
birine
şu
dat örneğine
geçelim
evet
bakın şimdi
auto
xyz
my data
initialize
eden
ifadenin
ne olduğu
ile
iti yok
çoğunlukla
fonksiyon
çağrılarında
kullanıyoruz
ama onunla
sınırlı
değil
tabii
şimdi
bir
lambda
ifadesi
yazıyorum
auto
f
eşittir
capture
x
int
e
return
i
çarpı
x
c++17
bu
syntax hatası
c++20
ile düzelttiler
yani
structure
binding
bu isimleri
capture
edemiyordunuz
lambda
ifadelerinde
ama
c++20
standartıyla
buna izin
verildi
iki
doğrudan
kullanabileceğimiz
ikinci yer
biziler
biziler de
doğrudan
core
syntax
düzeyinde
structure
binding'e
destek veriyor
int
are
ya da
string
are
eşittir
ali
can
nur
bakın
auto
s1
s2
s3
eşittir
are
bunun için özel bir koşul yok
dizler de oradan destek veriyor
yine aynı şekilde
dizinin
eleman sayısıyla
structure binding'de kullandığınız isim sayısı
aynı olmak zorunda
bu özellikle
fonksiyonların dizi döndürmesinde de işimizi kolaylaştırıyor
mesela
bakınız
int
a3
ya da int
köşeli parantezin içinde
bir using bildirimi yapayım
using
int
a3
şimdi
bu fonksiyonu
arkadaşlar
int
a3
türüne
referans döndürsün
ve ben de
bu fonksiyonuna bir çağrı yapmış olayım
fakat
fon'un geri dönüş değeri olan
referans semantiğiyle döndürdüğü
3 elemanın int
dizinin
elemanlarının değerlerini
değişkenlerde tutmak isteyeyim
o zaman doğrudan şöyle yazabilirim
mesela
auto
a1
a2
a3
eşittir
bu
ya da yerel bir dizi
statik ömürlü bir dizi de olabilirdi
int a
arkadaşlar mesela
kullanıldığı
yerlerden
bir tanesi
ifade
emirhan çelik
ifadenin sağ tarafı
referans refer olabilir mi
hayır
tam da o konuları konuşacaktık
ama vaktimiz de bitti
şöyle söyleyelim
bir derste biraz da yenmiştim
diziler
ve
yapı türleri için
yani
basit sınıf olarak
tanınanan yapı türleri için
doğrudan destek var
ama
diğer sınıflar için
geçerli olması
structured binding
syntaxının
couple
interfejisini
implement etmesine bağlı
yani
ilgili tür
ister standart
kütüphanenin türü olsun
ister
üçüncü parti
bir tür
bir type olsun
arkadaşlar
eğer
tuple size
amplitude'ini
özelleştirmişse
yine aynı şekilde
tuple elementi
özelleştirmişse
yani bunun için
specialization
oluşturmuşsa
partial specialization
ya da
full specialization
ve her bir eleman için
size t parametreli
index fonksiyonunu
yazmışsa
o tür
structured binding'i
destekliyor
yani derleyicinin
ürettiği kod
aslında
eğer
dizi ya da
o structure
değilse
derleyicinin
ürettiği kod
tuple size'ı
tuple elementi
ve get fonksiyonunu
kullanıyor
dolayısıyla
o
interfeysi
implemente eden
yani
tuple size
tuple element
ve get fonksiyonları
kendi türlerinizin de
structured binding'den
faydalanmasını
sağlayabilirsiniz
işte
standart kütüphanemizde
bu
tuple
interfeysine
implemente eden
türler
arkadaşlar
stud array
stud pair
ve stud tuple
dahil
buraya kadar
takip edebildik mi
evet
yani örneğin
pair'in
int
string açılımı
arkadaşlar
is
isp
bla bla bla
şöyle yazabilirim
auto
h
name
eşittir
isp
ama bunun level
olmasının nedeni
isterseniz deneyin
tuple elementin
pair'in
bu açılımı
specialization'ının
var olması
aynı şey
tuple size
ve get fonksiyonları
içinde geçerli
aynı durum
tuple'da da
söz konusu
peki
kaldığımız yeri
işaretledik
bir dakika
hafta devam edeceğiz
bugün biraz problemli oldu
elektrik kesintisi
nedeniyle
bir dahaki hafta
görüşmek üzere
herkese
iyi akşamlar
diliyorum
hoşçakalın
değerli arkadaşlar
iyi akşamlar
haber
abone ol
aí